my first a gaming system
was an atari 2600 pre-owned
and it had 20 games cartridges came with
it
how i came into possession of it was um
in the newspaper back in those days that
the wanna adds i don't know if they
still do it anymore kind of like
craigslist where people sell [ __ ] and
whatnot
so my dad was looking through the want
ads i wanted like you know i was always
bugging him
please can we get an atari 2600 please i
just want to play pac-man at home
everybody i know has one and stuff
except john kovac who has in television
but please please please can i get one
so finally you know we
they had three kids to raise and we were
kind of poor but my father found in the
one ads
somebody was selling an atari 2600 and
20 games
for a very reasonable price and so this
being
the early 80s um we got in a car
and drove 45 minutes out to freehold
township
and uh went to this farmhouse
where we knocked on the door as a family
like because buying a video game unit
was a big deal yeah mind you my parents
were progressive
we had had a video game unit in the
house
prior to the atari 2600 but it was
something my mom
bought on sale um like at two guys
when apparently they didn't work out it
was a triangular system
one one end had a gun in it because
there was a shooting game one end had a
steering wheel on it and a gear shift
and the other end had pong
uh turn turn knobs on it that looked
grosser than i meant but
knocks on it and stuff so we had had
that and the cartridges were like
triangular and [ __ ] i forget the name of
the die
but this 2600 this is the one that was
like please this will
make me normal like everybody else so
the whole family my mom my dad my
brother my sister and me
go to this farmhouse park knock on the
door
farm uh father opens the door brings us
into the house
three kids like roughly my age
you know and i was like early you know
arts so 11 12.
sitting on the couch looking
so [ __ ] broken so sad
as if they just found out like a pet
animal had died
and so my dad and the farmer dad
talked money and stuff like that and
then
i you know was curious naturally curious
so i said to one of the kids i was like
why don't you want this anymore and they
were like we do he's selling it because
and they pointed to the brother because
he got an f
in history and so suddenly i was like oh
my god i'm
complicit in the misery of another child
something you never want to experience
as a kid as a kid
you know it's always like us versus the
[ __ ] adults and [ __ ]
solidarity but i wanted that video game
system real [ __ ] bad
so rather than be like you know let's
get out of here which i think my parents
would have killed me like we came all
the way here
and my brother and sister would have
been like [ __ ] whatever he says we're
getting this [ __ ] game
but i didn't speak up i was just like
you know
shrug gave him the sucks to be you face
and then
we went home and i enjoyed the 2600 for
the next four years or whatever
i drove past that house periodically
when i went out to the freehold raceway
mall
and you know i'm a writer so of course
you you know you write the rest
of the history of that family and what
happened and how it dissolved
you know perhaps in mayhem and murder
based on the cruel punishment of their
atari being sold
for a lone f in history
like oh my god so my first uh
my atari 2600 came with blood on it on
its
joystick